again
what
very nice
oh
this morning
maybe
okay
okay
uh
all right
let's go
better
foreign
yes
okay
laughs
[Music]
thank you
oh
you tell me where to go
yes
i'm in the corner
smells
um
hi everyone
hello
so joining us today is ambassador
roberta jacobson
coordinator for the southern border
ambassador jacobson was the u.s
ambassador to mexico from 2016
to 2018. she previously served as u.s
assistant secretary of state for the
western hemisphere
affairs i had the pleasure of working
with her at that time and has focused on
latin america for more than 30 years as
a career
civil servant she's going to give some
remarks and then happy to take some
questions and as
always i will be the bad cop thank you
for joining us
so thank you all
good afternoon president biden has made
clear
from day one that he wants to change our
immigration system
doing so means truly building back
better because we can't just
undo four years of the previous
administration's actions overnight
those actions didn't just neglect our
immigration system they intentionally
made it worse
when you add a pandemic to that it's
clear it will take significant time to
overcome
we must build a better immigration
system that reflects our values as
americans
enforces our laws safeguards public
health and moves away from
cycles of irregular migration today i'm
here to talk about
what we're doing with partners in mexico
and central america to ensure that
people
don't make this dangerous journey and
instead have opportunities for economic
advancement
and safety at home the president has
committed to seeking four billion
dollars over four years to address the
root causes of migration
including corruption violence and
economic devastation
exacerbated by climate change as part of
that plan
we will address the causes that compel
individuals to migrate
including improving governance and
providing a foundation for investment
and economic opportunity
strengthening civilian security and the
rule of law
working across the whole of government
we will look at access to international
protection and refugee resettlement
and rethinking asylum processing to
ensure
fair and faster consideration
only by addressing those root causes can
we break the cycle of desperation and
provide hope for families
who clearly would prefer to stay in
their countries and provide a better
future for their children
president biden when he was vice
president visited the region many times
and is clear-eyed about the challenge he
insists now as he did then
that governments commit to being true
partners in creating the conditions for
growth and security
but i want to emphasize that the funds
we're asking for from congress
don't go to government leaders they go
to communities
to training to climate mitigation to
violence prevention
to anti-gang programs in other words
they go to the people who otherwise
migrate in search of hope and they will
have to have the participation of the
private sectors in those countries
who for too long have evaded taxes
underpaid workers
and failed to be part of the solution to
creating safe prosperous and democratic
countries
we've already begun specific actions to
both undo the previous administration's
policies
and to advance a new vision of
immigration we have ended the so-called
migrant protection protocols which sent
people back to mexico to wait
sometimes for years for a chance to
present their asylum claims
working with the government of mexico
international organizations and ngos
we have safely admitted over 1400
migrants
and closed the most dangerous face of
the mpp
the matamoros migrant camp today we are
announcing the restarting of the central
american miners program for children
to be reunited with a parent who is
legally in the united states
this program was ended abruptly by the
previous administration
leaving around 3 000 children already
approved for travel
stranded in phase 2 we'll be working to
improve the cam program to expand safe
and legal avenues
for to the united states i want to be
clear
neither in this neither this
announcement nor any of the other
measures
suggest that anyone especially children
and families with young children
should make the dangerous trip to try
and enter the us in an irregular fashion
the border is not open going forward we
will continue to look for ways to
provide
legal avenues in the region for people
needing protection
while we continue to enforce our laws
this is a process
we have a great deal to do but this
administration has made significant
progress
and we will continue to do so it
reflects who we are
as americans putting our values at the
center of our policy
thank you all right go ahead thank you
for doing this roberta
this four billion dollars that the
administration is seeking are you
seeking this as
part of a larger comprehensive
immigration package or as a stand-alone
bill well i think what you'll see is
that
four billion dollars in a central
american northern triangle strategy
will be part of our foreign assistance
request and we'll focus on the things we
know that work obviously it's not our
first rodeo
the vice president the president when he
was vice president worked on these
issues
we know how to get money to communities
that are most likely to send migrants
but also that are suffering the greatest
effect of two hurricanes this season etc
so it will be part of our overall
foreign assistance package
in the meantime we are focused on
getting
humanitarian assistance to these
countries after hurricanes
and iota so in that sense it's part of a
larger plan
but obviously there are parts of this
that will be on the domestic side as
well
to fix the whole um
extent of our immigration processing
what else is the administration doing
right now to work with these home
countries to send a message
to people don't come here don't send
your children there
right well i think you know one of the
most important things is
to make sure that we get communications
right and the message right and
and i'm happy to repeat that but i think
it's also important
that we work with the international
organizations that have very credible
voices
and have very good networks among
migrant sending communities
to dispel the myths and misinformation
that smugglers are using right when we
talk about the border not being open
and you know the ways in which we're
trying to dissuade people from making
making that dangerous journeys
the smugglers are conveying exactly the
opposite to people
so we need to make sure we get that
message out we also need to be
looking at things like the cam program
the central american miners program as i
talked about
and how we can expand that how we can
make that
you know eligibility greater but the
next
step is to look at solutions in the
region
right what more can we do to process
people legally who really do require
protection
so they don't have to make that journey
and we're looking at all of those things
and finally you said that this isn't
your first
rodeo should the administration have
been better prepared to handle
this influx of children before it
changed the policy
allowing them to stay in the country
well i think there's a couple things i
think what we're doing
right now is making a difference
in the home countries beginning to work
with governments
you know that couldn't start until
january 20th there's there is one
government at a time
you can't start changing processes of
government
building facilities all of this is
part of the plan as quickly as possible
to
make sure that our domestic processes
work more smoothly more quickly as i
mentioned
but also to work with foreign
governments and you can't do that
obviously till january 20th when you
when you take over but
there have been multiple engagements
with the government of mexico at very
high level with the government of
guatemala with the honduran government
in salvadoran
in the first you know six weeks of
government so i think we've gotten
off to a big start a fast start in that
engagement
jonathan uh thank you madam ambassador
uh on honduras how does the
administration balance his need for
cooperation from that government with
ongoing concerns about corruption there
particularly
uh federal prosecutors who say that the
president hernandez
was working on his plan to flood the
united states with cocaine
well i think one of the things that i
made clear in the opening
comments which i want to reiterate is
that none of the money that we're
looking to
get from from congress from the
taxpayers of the united states
goes to government leaders and so i i
don't think that means that presidents
are unimportant in these countries
but i do think that it's important to
understand
that we will be working with civil
society
with international organizations and
international ngos on the ground
um we will work with officials that we
can work with
but we also think it's really important
that these
countries make commitments really
explicit commitments
to advancing on anti-corruption
and in some places that will be hard to
do
if you've got officials for whom there
is a cloud and i think
we need to work with the organizations
that we can in countries
in some places we will work with
religious organizations ngos with etc
it's a challenge in countries that have
confronted
serious uh corruption risks like what
mechanism is in place where how do you
possibly safeguard
that funding to make sure it stays out
of the hands perhaps corrupt politicians
well i think one of the things that
we've always done always and and
31 years of the state department has
taught me this is we do end use
monitoring right our embassies
and and people that we work with are
looked at before they're recipients of
funds
and we do checks and we look at what's
being done with the funds right
we also don't deliver money in most
cases
we deliver training we deliver new
lighting facilities that reduce
violence and and crime you know so so a
lot of what you do
it's not handing over blank checks and i
think that's really important in this
thank you very much you're talking about
restarting cam
these other long-term goals for what
immigration policy should look like but
right now new cnn reporting shows that
unaccompanied migrant children are being
held
in these border patrol facilities for on
average 107 hours
that's up from i believe 77 hours on
average last week so
what is the bike administration doing
right now to fix that
well i think you know my part of this
focuses
much more on what we're doing at the end
of this
process in central america and mexico
i think all of us at every stage of this
process are doing everything we can
to make sure that children are well
careful cared for and moved
into facilities that are appropriate for
them
but i want to make a point again that
it's really important that people not
make the dangerous journey in the first
place
that we provide them with alternatives
to making that journey because it's
not safe on route
and so you know if if i could just
emphasize that
that it's really important that that
message get out
because the perception is not the same
as the reality in terms of the border
not being
open but we want to provide through cam
through other mechanisms
ways for some of these young people to
be reunited with family members in the
united states
they should not come would you describe
what's happening on the border as a
crisis
given how these numbers are spiking so
much week by week
you know i think that i i really i'm not
trying to be cute here but i think the
fact of the matter is
we have to do what we do regardless of
what anybody calls the situation and the
fact is
we are all focused on improving the
situation
on changing to a more humane
and efficient system and and whatever
you call it wouldn't change
what we're doing because we have urgency
from the president
on down to fix our system
and make sure that we are better at
dealing with the hopes and the dreams of
these migrants in their home country
all right madam ambassador do you think
it's a coincidence that as soon as trump
and his immigration policy were on the
way out and biden and his
stated policy were on the way in this
historic surge
at the border started well first of all
one of the things i think is important
is we've seen surges before
surges tend to respond to hope
and there was a significant hope
for a more humane policy after
four years of you know pent up demand
so i don't know whether i would call
that a coincidence but i certainly think
that
the idea that a more humane policy would
be in place
may have driven people to make that
decision
but perhaps more importantly it
definitely drove smugglers
to express
disinformation to spread disinformation
about what was now possible
and we know that if the change in
administrations brought hope
then from your perspective is this
search good
i don't think that's what i just said i
think it's a reflection of how migrants
feel at a particular time
i think what we are doing is making sure
that we respond to that hope for people
who need protection
we respond to that hope in a way that
their cases can be adjudicated more
quickly
but i don't think anybody would say that
coming to the united states in an
irregular fashion
is a good thing that's why i've tried
repeatedly
to dissuade people from from listening
to those smugglers
but we're going to try our best to do
everything we can
at each end of this in the united states
but especially in central america and
mexico to ensure we have safe
orderly and legal migration
go ahead um president biden when he was
vice president was very active
on working with the northern triangle
countries and
i was just wondering were there lessons
that you or he or other administration
officials many of whom are
in in jobs in this administration have
learned about how to deal with those
countries or how to deal with foreign
aid to them
um that are informing how you're
approaching things now and
just to kind of follow up a little bit
on what peter was asking
uh are you concerned at all of that kind
of mixed messaging that at the same time
that you are telling people not to come
that the
journey is dangerous that because you
are offering
this this talk about a more humanitarian
process that people
will not you know pay attention to the
fact that they could apply from home
from their home country that they would
still come that they are still
you know so hopeful that there really is
kind of a conflicting message coming
from washington institute
so on the first question the question of
learning things from when the vice
president was leading a lot of our
efforts in central america previously
um i think yes that's a resounding yes
both the president and all of us who
worked with him
on that for him on that um learned a
great deal
and i think that it's really important
that we put that to use now
one of the things he thinks is so
important is being really explicit
with leadership in the countries from
which migrants are coming
about commitments that they need to make
because overcoming the reasons people
migrate
is not going to be the united states job
alone
right if we realize that it's lack of
good governance
economic opportunity and security issues
or
violence then some of those require
commitments by the governments on
anti-corruption and transparency
on creating governments that function
better to provide services for their
country so
he's very clear on being sure that we
get those commitments from leaders and
holding them to it right the money is
not a tap that gets turned on all at
once
you have to make sure that you're
continuing to follow those issues
so i think there's a lot of things we
learned and a lot of things we learned
about
ensuring that funds get to the
communities that are really in need
whether it's post-hurricane or uh coffee
rust which was ravaging guatemala and
honduras or
you know a historic drought i think
when you look at the issue of mixed
messages
it is difficult at times to convey both
hope in the future and the danger
that is now and that is what we're
trying to do
and i i ca i will certainly agree that
we are trying to
walk and chew gum at the same time we
are trying to convey
to everybody in the region that we will
have legal processes for people
in the future and we're standing those
up as soon as we can
but at the same time
you cannot come through irregular means
it's dangerous
and you know the majority of people will
be sent
out of the united states because
that is the truth of it we want to be
honest with people and so
we are trying to send both messages and
smugglers are only trying to send one
message
so we're relying on every means we can
to get that
message out there and that leads me to
want to
reiterate as i did before
yes
irregular ambassador can you say a word
more about what you're talking about in
terms of the private sector can you
explain what
you're envisioning there and like what
exactly do you need and then
just to sort of as a second question you
know you're talking about being really
explicit with these countries but what
sort of
leverage does the united states actually
have to
affect change in those countries like
what what exactly
can you do yeah let me take that second
one first only because
look in the end i think the implication
of your question which is quite right
is we can't make the changes
we can encourage them we can help
support them with resources both
technical assistance and
and funding but we can't make those
changes the changes have to come
in the northern triangle countries what
i should say is my own experience from
traveling to those places
there are myriad people and
organizations who are trying to make
those changes
and part of what we want to do is
empower them
whether that's more effective you know
economic support whether it's training
for young people whether it's
anti-gang uh programs whether it's
mothers clubs
and and empowering local communities
all of that gets done through people on
the ground not by the united states
so we want to be able to empower those
actors
i also think that it's really important
when you say what leverage do you have
well i do think that
working as partners with these countries
means sitting down
and talking about what we can do
together but also
if american taxpayers funds are going to
be used
then that is a certain amount of
leverage the president
really wants to move forward on this but
he
won't unless he feels he has those
commitments on an ongoing basis
is that leverage um you know funds are
are
sometimes important means of having that
conversation
your first question was on
[Music]
remind me oh well let me just follow up
no no no you can't follow up you have to
come back to the first one
i mean are you saying explicitly the us
could withhold
funding whether it's state department
aid or usaid
i think the really important thing to
know is we're looking forward to getting
this
um proposal before congress and
having congress act on it and what comes
after that
you know i just don't know um you know
the
an executive branch can always you know
adjust things like that
i also think it's really important to
understand you asked about the private
sector
the private sector in all of these
countries in central america in
particular is a really important player
here
and and i think to be very honest
we have not seen seen them step up one
of the mechanisms that was really
effective under the obama
biden administration was for every
dollar
that the u.s put into an assistance
program
we asked for private sector
organizations
local chambers of commerce or business
organizations
to either match us or exceed us this
gives the private sector skin in the
game
it makes sure that they are part of the
solution
if the governments in these countries
don't always have enough resources to do
what they should
to improve the economic opportunity for
people
there are private sector organizations
and and members of the private sector
the business community
who need to be part of that solution and
and so we just feel that that's really
an important element to this
we talked about international
organizations governments ngos
i don't want to leave out the business
community as a as a participant
okay last two last three if you have
time yeah
okay thank you so ambassador
just to follow up on andrea's question i
mean i understand when you're saying you
want to empower these civil societies
in these part countries but can you make
the link between empowering those civil
societies and actually eliminate
eliminating the push factor to stop them
from coming
to this country so how much of it is an
international age policy versus
an anti you know an immigration policy
that's my first question
and then the second one if you can speak
more specifically about the requirements
that
you're making to these countries in
terms of anti-corruption practices what
are the specific measures of success
and and how to ensure that they're taken
yes well in the first question
i think this is both an international
aid issue as well as a as a
policy issue both for you know for us
and the countries that we're working
with
on the one hand it is clearly a resource
issue you have two greater than category
four hurricanes
it's an iota within a 15-day period
you've got
reports that suggest that literally
multiple millions of people in guatemala
and honduras are food insecure now
that is clearly something you need to be
looking at humanitarian assistance and
aid to try and remedy
now in the longer term when you're
looking
at increased pace of natural disasters
because of climate change
or you're looking at ways to
ensure that agricultural policy you know
changes in countries
or that training is given or that
students including girls remain in
school
those are longer term policy questions
that
need to be addressed with our partners
in the region because they all have an
impact on whether migration flows
increase or not
and so when the president talks about
root causes
some of this is immediate humanitarian
aid
but a lot of it is policy and aid
together
making sure that you tackle the root
causes of migration otherwise what you
see
is continued cycles right to break that
cycle of migration
sustainably you have to work both
on the on the specific commitments for
governments
i think that's something that we would
want to discuss with the countries
involved before we discuss it publicly
thank you
the president's executive powers do you
think the president will consider using
his executive powers to reunite
families who have been separated under
zero tolerance
well that certainly
outside of the family reunification task
force that was created which is exactly
to do that
beyond that are you talking about people
who are not in the same country
the families that were that were
separated would the president use any
more executive power
i'm sorry but do you mean families who
were separated when in the united states
during uh zero tolerance in the past
well that's exactly what the family
reunification task force is doing
right so nothing beyond that it deals
with the whole universe of people
separated during that policy so not that
i know of
okay last two in the back a couple
questions
uh congress appropriated almost 1.4
billion
for this fiscal year for the border wall
that you are not building
how much of that is left are you guys
redirecting it at all and to what
along the border right now uh secondly
you discuss messaging
arguably your predecessor's entire
theory of their immigration agenda was
that they were trying to send this
message
don't come america is close to irregular
migration
so obviously you're pursuing some
different policies but what can you
actually do
differently than they did to try to get
that message if
you know it wasn't fixed already with
that kind of oppressive messaging
well on the first question regarding the
border wall the president has been very
clear about
um ending the national emergency or the
emergency of the border that
that was used to justify the wall and
and obviously not
proceeding with it the exact um
legal requirements and where that those
funds might go i just i just don't know
i'm sorry
um let me let me talk about
the message issue i mean i think
i think it's really important to
understand that
that you can't and shouldn't say
in this administration's opinion that
the only way to message do not come in
an irregular fashion
is to act as cruelly as you possibly can
separate children from their parents
return people to places that like the
camp
migrant camp in matamoros you know for
up to two plus years at a time
and that's the only way that you can get
your message across
this administration's belief is that we
can get our message across that it is a
more humane
policy by opening up avenues
of legal migration which will
encourage people to take those legal
options
and go through the asylum process if
they're
seeking that and not take the irregular
road i think you have to find
different ways to message but if
messaging reflects your actions
that is why we are increasing the
actions for legal migration
so that the messages you have another
option
thank you if i may ask a question in
spanish for our audience
[Music]
immediately
[Music]
thank you
okay i can't promise it'll always be
that rapid when i promise to bring
someone to the briefing room but
we'll try we'll do our best we'll do our
best
um a couple of other items for all of
you at the top
with today's expected passage of the
rescue plan
i can announce that the president will
sign the bill at the white house on
friday afternoon
we spent a lot of time of course from
the podium talking about the mechanics
of how a bill becomes a law and i know
there's lots of interest in what comes
next
so once it's passed the bill text will
be rechecked printed
and signed by the appropriate leaders in
the house and senate
the house clerks will then deliver it to
the white house for the president's
signature
we expect that delivery to happen
sometime tomorrow and then the president
will sign it
on friday we of course are moving full
speed ahead on the implementation of the
bill
because we know the american people need
help and need it as soon as possible
the way we are also working on looking
ahead to implementation
i wanted to make sure you all saw
secretary yellen's speech before the
national league
of cities yesterday promising to get aid
out to state and local governments
obviously this is a key component of the
package and one that will help keep
cops firefighters local officials
in their jobs and we are looking there
they are
looking for ways to maximize of course
the impact of every dollar
that's exactly what the president did
when he served as the point person on
the implementation of the recovery act
in 2009 partnering with
mayors governors and other officials to
get help to them quickly and in a way
that kept waste fraud and abuse to
two-tenths of one percent so
he knows directly that this the passage
and signing of the bill is just the
beginning
and he will uh he plans to appoint
somebody to run point on implementation
i don't have any personnel announcements
today but
that will certainly be part of our path
moving forward
also today as you know the president
will join the ceos of johnson johnson
and merck
to discuss their historic partnership
that will produce more life-saving
vaccines for americans and the world
president biden will also announce that
he is directing uh
he is planning to direct he's directing
i should say jeff science our covid
coordinator
and hhs uh an hhs team to procure an
additional
100 million doses of the johnson johnson
vaccine
he's doing this because in a wartime
effort which is what we consider this
we need maximum flexibility we want to
be oversupplied and over prepared
there's also a chance that we'll
encounter an unexpected challenge
on new need in our vaccination efforts
and we're preparing for just
that the president will also discuss uh
the meeting today
at the meeting he's having today during
his remarks and i'll also
uh address uh of course our uh the
passage of the rescue plan during those
remarks
as well uh last item i believe here lots
going on here today
um on march 18 through 19 national
security adviser jake sullivan
and secretary of state tony blinken will
meet with director
yang ji chur and state councilor wang yi
in anchorage of china of course
the meeting will follow the president's
convening of the quad at the leader
level as well as his participation in
the g7
leaders meeting just a few weeks ago uh
secretary
lincoln and secretary austin's trip to
japan and korea two of our closest
regional allies
and national security advisor sullivan's
multiple engagements
with japanese korean australian canadian
and european counterparts
including a european quad meeting next
week
it was important to us that this
administration's first meeting with
chinese officials be held on
american soil and occur after we have
met and consulted closely with partners
and allies in both
asia and europe and as you know a number
of those conversations have happened at
the presidential level and of course
at the secretary of state and national
security advisory level as well
the meeting is an opportunity to address
a wide range of issues
including ones where we have deep
disagreements uh we intend to discuss
our expectations
and we'll be frank in explaining
beijing's actions and behavior
behavior challenge uh to the security
prosperity
and our concerns about challenges they
post the security
uh and values of the united states and
our allies and partners
uh we will also talk about areas where
we can cooperate of mutual
interests and we are coming to these
discussions of course
clear-eyed the meeting also provides an
opportunity to emphasize how the united
states will stand up for
the rules-based international system and
a free and open indo-pacific
as the president has said we approach
our relationship with the chinese from a
position of strength and locks up with
our allies and
partners with that go ahead jonathan
thank you so much
you said the president will be signing
the bill on friday can you walk us
through
what will happen next the president
himself has expressed regret
uh that the 2009 economic
others veterans of the administration
field similarly
can you explain to us what we're going
to see from the president from
surrogates how is this message going to
be delivered to the american people how
do you sell this bill
sure well uh the president the vice
president the first
lady the second gentleman number of
members of her cabinet will be
communicating directly with the american
people engaging directly with the
american people
and all sending a clear message help is
on the way
uh over the next few weeks uh we are
going to swiftly
put in place implementation plans i've
touched on a little bit of that
uh and and plans to get aid to the
people in places that need it the most
as quickly as possible
this is of course a continuation of the
work we've done over the last two months
to build support for the rescue plan
communicating directly with the american
people
building support among mayors governors
labor leaders the business community and
other stakeholders
will be emphasizing a number of
components that are in the package
and really having a conversation this is
important to the president personally
having a conversation directly with
people about how they can benefit
addressing questions they have even
taking their feedback on implementation
and how to make it clear and we've
talked a little bit about in here people
have questions like
what do i need to do anything to get my
check how do i benefit from
the uh the health benefits what about uh
you know what
what funding will go to my school he
wants to ensure that
people have access to this information
so uh he will be hitting the road the
vice president will be hitting the road
the first lady will be hitting the road
uh we will have uh people out
communicating directly in communities
but we'll also use a range of tools
at our disposal including including
engaging in
communicating through digital means uh
doing local interviews
and also utilizing a number of members
of our cabinet
who have key roles in the implementation
i reference secretary yellen
uh of course in her role obviously the
irs has some key roles here
uh but uh he will be uh tapping into
uh the cabinet to also play a role in
communicating and engaging with the
public
i'll follow on this and then one other
matter on this you know
the president obviously is addressing
the nation tomorrow night in prime time
uh is this part of it the idea of what
happens next because of the package
going to be
part of that speech can you preview a
little bit about what the message to the
american people is going to be tomorrow
i expect i'll have more to
say tomorrow about the speech and i want
to just give him a chance to go through
the speech again and make sure i'm
previewing it in a way that is
consistent with where it will land
uh but as i've talked about a little bit
in here this is tomorrow marks the 50th
day
of the administration uh it also marks
one year since the country shut down
and the president believes it is
important to take a look back
of the journey the american people have
been on the sacrifices that have been
made the lives that have been lost
and also look ahead and he will be uh
talking more about how he will approach
uh this uh war against the pandemic
moving forward
uh and lay out some more specifics of
what the american people can expect
a u.n report out today says the us is
among the countries
lagging behind on climate-friendly
projects in cobit economic recovery
spending throughout the globe
uh when is this administration going to
start moving forward on the 2 trillion
climate change package that was such a
big part of that candidate
biden's uh campaign it's only day 49.
jonathan we're about to pass a historic
the most progressive bill in american
history it's
it's be it passing today uh look i would
say that the president
believes that and he talked about this
on the campaign trail as you as you
mentioned was certainly a promise of his
that
uh we can create the the united states
and many other countries around the
world we'll
we'll focus on here can create good
paying union jobs
that are also consistent with our
objective of just addressing the climate
crisis
and certainly that is central to how
he's thinking about his agenda moving
forward
those policy discussions are still
ongoing uh
but i can assure you that he intends to
deliver on the promises he made on the
campaign trail
and intends to deliver on the promises
he made about creating good-paying union
jobs that
uh also are consistent with his goal of
addressing the climate crisis i should
say go ahead
hey jen um on the 100 million new doses
you said that the goal is to be over
supply what's the goal for that
oversupply is it to be held in reserve
for kids
is it to be donated to other countries
is it
to be held in reserve in case people
need to get shots again
next year what's the plan for that extra
dosage
well uh first the president's focus uh
every day when he wakes up is ensuring
uh every american we can ensure that
every american has access to a vaccine
and that we
are vaccinating the people in this
country but here are a couple of the
factors
that were have have weighed in on our
decision to purchase
an additional 100 million doses we still
don't know which
vaccine will be most effective on kids
we still don't know the impact of
variance or the need for booster shots
and
these doses can be used for booster
shots as well as needed obviously that's
still being studied by the fda
but again we want to be over prepared as
i noted earlier
we also need maximum flexibility so
johnson and johnson
the vaccine has unique benefits it's a
one-shot vaccine
it can be stored in the fridge and not a
freezer it's highly effective
as the others are as well against
hospitalization and death but we are
really looking for maximum flexibility
here as we are still considering a
couple of those
um pieces i mentioned uh which is most
effective with children
the effectiveness on addressing variants
and
um and of course boosters as i noted and
then on the coveted relief bill which is
being voted on in the house
right now uh how quickly will school
districts be able to
access that money and will they be able
to implement it in time to make
safety changes for this school year
which
in many parts of the country is only
going to last another three months
you're absolutely right and a fair
amount of the funding is also
we we expect will be likely used for
forward planning
right so so schools that need to plan
for we need to hire temporary teachers
right now but we need to ensure we can
keep them on the job
in a year and two years we need to make
facility upgrades it really depends
school to school
in terms of the timeline for
implementation i know that's something
that our
department of education is going to be
looking at and of course
uh the implementation team that will be
focused on
getting these dollars out the door so we
will certainly uh plan to give you an
update as we have a better
timeline on the on the calendar and then
finally on another front design
registered journalist andrea sahur
is currently on trial over her coverage
of a racial justice protest
last summer she's been charged with
failure to disperse and interference
with official
acts as the biden administration believe
that these charges should be dropped and
will the president or anyone in the
administration urge polk county iowa
prosecutors
to drop the charges i'm happy to discuss
this with our team i'm not as familiar
with the case but
i will look into it we'll get you back
and answer sure go ahead kayla
first off has president biden been
briefed by his delegation that went to
the border over the weekend
and does he now feel the need to go to
the border if he has been briefed by
them
sure well i can confirm for you that the
president did receive a briefing earlier
today
from members of his team that visited
the border region this past weekend
i will note he receives regular
briefings on immigration and
the economy on covid on a range of
issues
that the country and the uh the
administration is facing he heard from
the delegation on what they observed
during their visit to the border region
and the facilities they toured but they
all they spent the majority of their
time
discussing what steps can be taken to
expedite processes
to move more quickly uh to move the
process more quickly to meet the
administration's goal of getting these
children
placed with vetted and confirmed
families moving them quickly as as
related to your question earlier out of
border patrol facilities and into these
shelters and then ultimately into
these homes i don't have anything to
preview for you in terms of a trip
obviously a delegation going to
the border and visiting these facilities
is something that can be done with a
much smaller footprint than the
president of the united states traveling
but i don't have anything to preview in
terms of a trip and earlier you said
you're going to or the president is
going to pick someone to kind of
run the implementation of the corona
iris relief package
does the white house anticipate that
there could be delays in implementing
that because it is such a big bill
no i wouldn't it wouldn't uh imply or i
was not trying to imply that
only that we know that this will not all
be implemented in four days or a week or
what have you this will take some time
and we want to ensure that there is a
person responsible and accountable to
the implementation
that's something the president felt
worked when he was vice president
and so it was an indication of that but
there are a number of
uh cabinet members who also play pivotal
roles here i referenced of course
secretary yellen
secretary cardona will play a pivotal
role of course in the reopening of
schools
and so there are already officials
within the administration but this this
can be it has been used in the past is
up more of a coordinating mechanism and
how long do you think that
implementation will take
i can't give you really a timeline of
that obviously there are things
there are different components as you
well know right getting the checks out
the door
uh our our treasury team and our
economic team are crunching the numbers
on that we hope to have an update for
all of you
soon on that obviously reopening schools
as nancy was asking about
it really is school district to school
district in terms of what their needs
what their needs will be which schools
need funding which districts need
funding
there are things like unemployment
insurance which obviously is is applied
to different uh mechanisms so
like there are pieces of this that are
just going to be implemented over time
some that can be done more
rapidly and quickly but obviously this
is our focus and our uh
and our priority in the days ahead and
my last question on johnson johnson
he is going to announce that they are
trying to get another 100 million doses
this afternoon but
the administration told governors
yesterday on their weekly call that they
should only expect to get 400 000 doses
of the johnson johnson vaccine next week
that is far behind what the johnson
johnson contract with the federal
government
that they were supposed to have ready
when it was authorized uh by the fda
so is he going to confront the johnson
and johnson executives he's meeting with
today about why they are
so far behind on production well as you
know caitlin
we uh he invoked the defense production
act in part because he wanted to
uh and our team jeff science and others
have been working closely with
johnson and johnson and merck of course
to expedite
the production of vaccines to ensure
that they can be
available on the timeline they've
committed to i will say that this 100
million
uh that was announced that's being
announced this afternoon
is more for the second half of this year
and not for
it's not we're not adding additional
doses expected on that same timeline
uh but i'm certain they will be
discussing of course uh the need to
ensure that the deadlines are met and
that um
that we have the vaccines and the doses
needed to get them in the arms of the
american people
go ahead andrew so on the next scene the
head of the wto and others are calling
for
greater efforts to be made by advanced
economies
developing big countries and rich
countries to get more vaccine into
developing countries
you've just announced that you want to
be over prepared here in the us
and what is the united states doing to
ensure that
these vaccines get out to other
countries and
do you favor a waiver of intellectual
property
protections under the wto to ensure that
that moves more quickly
or you know what's your perspective on
on the kind of a third way
that would be just increasing licensing
well first the president is deeply
focused on the issue of expanding global
vaccinations uh
and manufacturing and delivery which
will all be critical to end the pandemic
but as we've also said he's first and
foremost focused on
ensuring americans have access to
vaccines as soon as possible
uh uh in the in this period of time and
we've obviously made a great deal of
progress on that front
i don't have anything more to preview
for you in terms of uh what that will
look like
we first need to focus on right now
we're still in a circumstance where
there isn't enough supply for the amer
for the number of americans who want
to get the vaccination so that's really
our focus at this point in time but
certainly it's a point of discussion uh
with uh his counterparts and with
uh uh the counterparts of other members
of our national security team
so you don't wanna say anything about
the waiver i don't have anything more
for you to predict
and then on that question of vaccinating
children you mentioned that you're not
sure which vaccine will be most
effective
factory has talked about getting uh high
school students vaccinated by fall
and elementary school kids in the spring
you have a sense
of when every american could be
vaccinated i mean
you know you know we've you've talked
about having enough on hand for
adults to be vaccinated by the summer um
or by the end of may actually well we
will have enough supply
right but the president is the first to
say that
we can't do this alone and that
certainly a component of this that is
vitally important is ensuring that
people understand
across the country that these vaccines
are safe and they are effective and we
are still
uh going to focus on combating
uh the issues of misinformation and of
course a vaccine hesitancy in a range of
communities
uh the fda as you know would be the ones
running point on
approval of vaccines for children i
can't really predict
when children will be vaccinated and we
don't know when the fda may approve a
vaccine
but our role is ensuring there's enough
supply and that there is enough
distribution
we've made a great deal of progress on
that more work to be done uh but i can't
make any predictions beyond that
go ahead um on a couple things first
president biden
when he was vice president kind of was
the person who ran point on
uh the 2009 um recovery bill
would you expect that vice president
harris might take on a similar role he
has
you know done done a lot
put her in a very similar position to
the one that he had with president obama
well that's true i mean the president
has said that he wants
uh the vice president to be the first in
the room and the last in the room
when he has important briefings when
there are important policy decisions and
discussions
that are taking place and that certainly
is how he is
operating or they are operating as a
team together
in terms of what role she may play in
the implementation i don't have anything
to preview for you on that
she will certainly be traveling she's a
key voice and asset for the
administration and she'll be
uh communicating about the uh impact uh
of the uh of the american rescue plan
and how it's gonna help the american
people um
over the course of the next few weeks um
ron claims said last night
that um the president's speech to a
joint session of congress
won't be for a few weeks um and he was
kind of suggesting that there was going
to be this time period
where the administration is focused on
um
you know promoting the bill that just
passed um can you kind of confirm that
and provide any more information on sort
of
how you're thinking about the rest of
march into april
um you know promoting this
arp versus moving on to the buildback
fighter
sure i don't have an exact breakdown of
timeline and i don't think ron was
intending to give one either only to
convey which is i think why you're
asking that
uh the president the vice president and
all of us in the administration believe
it's important to take a moment
to or a few moments i should say to
communicate directly with the american
people
about the benefits of the package to
ensure they understand
that help is on the way in a range of
forms and to do that in communities and
directly with people who
we are hoping understand the benefits of
this package
so i expect that to mean a couple of
trips for the president the vice
president and others but i don't have
kind of an
end date for that and certainly part of
the um
part of the focus internally is on
ongoing discussions about what is next
and
what components of the president's
buildback better agenda
what the order is the format the size
and those just uh those decisions have
been finalized quite yet
one other thing that you kind of hinted
you might have an answer for yesterday
which is another thing related to ron
the the clearing
national clearing house for vaccine
information um
you know we here in the bloomberg seat
are very interesting i know the answer
is very excited about the website um
which
which many people are um you know i
would say
um you know as you know it the the
website is is being implemented as a
vaccine finder i should say
is being implemented as a pilot program
we've always been open to
expanding the pilot program and we're
certainly looking into that
we're also looking into and others have
asked this question
how we can better assist uh state and
local governments who have their own
websites where
they are utilized by many members of the
local community and effective but
sometimes they have
technical issues so we're looking at
addressing it from a couple of
um different directions but every option
remains on the table we're also
considering setting up call centers
organizing navigators
help to help individuals schedule
appointments which sometimes can be the
issue so
i don't have a major update other than
to convey that
it's a pilot program we've always been
open to expanding it
and certainly a range of options remain
on the table and sometimes in some
states their local website is
working quite well and they just need
some technical assistance
good thank you jen uh you've been
telling migrants from
right there for a month now all the way
back to february 10th that now
is not the time to come but they are
coming in bigger numbers every day so
do you have a messaging problem well i
would say that in the last
administration we had a morality problem
and uh children were being pulled from
the arms of their parents
and kids were being sent back on a
treacherous journey
and that's not the approach of this
administration so
certainly we understand that means there
will be more kids
who are crossing the border we made a
policy decision that that was the right
humane step to take but i think it's
also important for people to understand
that the vast majority of people who
come
to our border are turned away are sent
back
to their countries what we're talking
about here are unaccompanied
children and what our focus is on is
ensuring that there
are safe places for these kids to go
that have acces where they have access
to educational resources
health and medical attention legal
assistance as needed
and that we can expedite the vetting so
that they can get to families and
sponsors
uh where they can have their cases
adjudicated but centralized
administration is gone
tomorrow is 50 days of finance there are
migrants showing up wearing t-shirts
that say bye and please let us in
and candidate by this one who said i
would end this notion for the first time
in history that people seeking asylum
have to be in squalor on the other side
of the river
why doesn't he come out and just say now
it's not the time
well he actually did an interview with
univision about a week weaker week and a
half ago where he conveyed a similar
message and we've conveyed that at every
opportunity that we have
i will say we are as you noted almost 50
days in
we are digging ourselves out of a broken
and dismantled system roberta uh master
jacobson referenced this in her
opening as well when it comes to
engaging with countries addressing the
root causes
we couldn't start doing that until
january 20th there are programs like the
relaunching of the central american
minors program
which was ended by the prior
administration in 2017
and that meant that uh that that program
which would have allowed for people to
apply from the region we had to restart
that program
so we're working to fix the mess of the
last couple of years
it's going to take some time but this is
clearly a priority for the president
we're looking at a range of options
which include
the opening of additional facilities it
includes
steps we can take to expedite the
processing it includes
uh application and implementation of
these cdc guidelines that
were just came out that allow for more
children to be
housed safely in these facilities so
we're looking at every option possible
to help address
the challenges we're facing and you
mentioned those cdc guidelines does the
white house
think it's a problem that when the cdc
tells these migrant
shelter facilities that they can be at
full capacity
if they are careful about covid many of
them do
but when the cdc tells schools that they
can open
in person at full capacity many of them
don't
is there a school in particular that you
have as an example that didn't
do that are most schools in this country
at full capacity with
in-person learning is there a specific
school though that is not following the
cdc guidelines of
of implementing the mitigation steps so
they can reopen
the cdc is saying schools you can be at
every school
can be at full capacity the cdc
guideline the cdc guidelines just to be
clear because i think this is very
important to be very clear and specific
don
they gave eight mitigation steps that
schools can take
to safely reopen a number of schools
have actually recently
reopened schools in washington dc some
have schools in many districts across
the country
but each school district needs to make
the decision about whether they
are able to take those mitigation steps
the president has also been clear
some of these school districts need
additional funding there's 160 billion
dollars
in this package that he's going to sign
into law later this week secretary of
education will be quite focused on
working with school districts to
help them reopen but more school
districts are reopening
more kids are in classrooms every single
day but since they are not all back from
an administration
position or from your perspective have
the border patrol
unions and the hhs unions been easier to
work with than
the teachers unions i i think that's a
little bit of mixing
different circumstances i would say that
all in tight quarters uh
i mean a classroom but not quite funny
not quite i i would say that let's let's
take a responsible approach to the two
issues okay
one is school's reopening there's been
eight mitigation steps that have been
announced by the cdc to implement right
every school district is going to work
to implement those on a timeline that is
uh they can effectively do many school
districts are reopening right
many are reopening every single week and
day and week right
that is a different circumstance than
what we are seeing at the border
and the hhs oversees these these
facilities right
they're working with uh they're working
on ensuring we can have more kids safely
they are working to implement cdc
guidelines but they're different
circumstances
and certainly we're working with the
school districts and we're also working
with
hhs to open these facilities or to
ensure that kids are treated
uh with safety and care in these
facilities
okay go ahead thanks jen um just a
little bit more on the quad
you mentioned yesterday that one of the
issues that will be discussed is
how the leaders can work together to
combat the pandemic
might that discussion include a strategy
to counter
vaccine diplomacy from china and russia
uh you know i think there'll be a range
of topics discussed and i know that it
is
um a concern of a number of leaders
around the world including of course
president biden
and i'm sure we'll have a readout of the
quad meeting tomorrow once it's
completed
a little bit more on the announcement if
you can review it can you expect
anything in terms of
how the quad what kind of commitment
they would give in terms of helping
other countries
again i i know they'll discuss a range
of issues tomorrow but
i think it's important to just take a
quick a little bit of a step back
because this is a
a meeting that covers a range of topics
of course i'm sure covid which is a
pandemic what everyone in the world is
dealing with will be
a topic of discussion but uh there'll be
issues like climate that are addressed
economic cooperation
i'm sure they'll have a range of issues
to bring up and we will provide a
readout when the meeting concludes
tomorrow a little bit more on that in
terms of the military balance i mean we
know that china just announced a huge
defense spending 6.8
i believe for this year is that also a
tough item
in the agenda uh i don't think i have
more to preview than what we've already
offered
we will of course have a readout when
the meeting concludes
uh there are a range of topics on the
mind of all of these leaders
as i've noted in here before we
anticipate the meeting discussing
a range of the crises we're facing as a
global community from
covid to climate economic cooperation
i'm sure they all will bring up a number
of
issues and we'll have a robust readout
when the meeting concludes
go ahead uh a few questions like sure um
so in california republicans are seeking
to nationalize the recall affair
against governor gavin newsom and really
make it a referendum on on covet
policies you know the other day
bernie sanders tweeted that it's time
for democrats to unite
and rally on nuisance behalf against the
recall does the president have any plans
to
personally or otherwise support newsome
if this does make it on the ballot and
you know becomes an off-year campaign
we're not quite there yet we've spoken
out in support of governor newsom and
against the recall so
that remains our position all right also
in california you know
we at the san francisco chronicle are
finding that school districts are saying
even with this influx of money coming
from the package
there's still lots of reasons they're
not sure if they can reopen even you
know by this fall including building
consensus around how to do it
there's been some criticism that the cdc
guidance is actually too conservative
and prohibitive
including the six feet distance rule
that schools either have to
ignore or not open you know if there are
still schools that aren't open
by this fall would the administration
consider it a failure and
what more could they possibly do to help
those schools we have several months
before the fall
six months except five months okay i
will stop doing
math now uh this is our secretary of
education
miguel cardona this is his number one
priority what he is focused on the
president has asked him to lead this
effort
and he is holding a school summit he
will be working with
school districts including i'm sure in
california and san francisco and others
to work to address what they feel the
challenges are to reopening
whether it's funding that's needed
whether it's consensus building that
needs to
to happen the president wants schools to
be open five days a week
wants kids to be learning in school and
we're gonna do everything we can to
ensure that's happening
and lastly on the subject of today's
briefing you know
immigration and border policy it covers
so many different agencies there's
homeland security there's hhs as we've
discussed there's
state department department of justice
which we don't talk about as much as a
huge piece of this
is there someone in this administration
who is
coordinating all of these disparate
pieces ultimately
you know where does the bus stop who is
making sure that all these different
agencies
are coordinating to the administration's
overall goals
well ultimately the president is
responsible for
the policy and key issues and key
challenges the country is facing and
immigration
is certainly one of them you're right
there are a number of agencies involved
in this effort
um but i will say i would say they're
all playing a pivotal role
the department of homeland security the
uh we don't have a health and human
services secretary confirmed yet
when he is he will play a pivotal role
but a whole team at hhs as you know
so this is being coordinated uh in part
from our national security team but
ultimately
uh it's the president who makes
decisions about the policy that's why he
asked the team to go to the border and
why he
asked to receive a briefing and that's
something as i noted that happened this
morning
go ahead follow up on implementation
okay on the release package
implementation where there specific
lessons that president biden when he was
in charge of
doing this in 2009 that he learned about
that effort that will be applied
in this effort particularly in terms of
um
efficiency and reducing waste and fraud
that kind of things but in general any
specific lessons that he learned about
that it's good to have one person in
charge
sure is structured very differently as
as you remember and i'm sure many people
remember the a big chunk of the uh
recovery act uh was
around shovel ready projects this is of
course a very different type of
bill i think some of the lessons we're
already implementing
including having a point person in
charge including ensuring there's a
sustained campaign
that is not just about the president of
the united states or the vice president
of the united states speaking about the
benefits but that really engages
our partners and allies whether it's
governors or
mayors local community leaders to ensure
there is
effective implementation and
communication about the package
he also wants to lift up and this is
something that's been important to him
in general but is very applicable to
this package
members of his cabinet so that they can
be front-facing
and play a very public role in engaging
with the public and ensuring they
understand components and pieces of a
package like this
there are pieces in this package that uh
of course are related to
uh helping veterans there are pieces of
this package that really
really to helping rural communities and
he wants to ensure
that uh members of his cabinet are are
playing key roles there
that's something that of course was done
a little bit in 2009 but can can
definitely be built on and
i think we will venture to do that
equal rights amendment the house is
expected to vote soon i think next week
on um
eliminating the uh now expired deadline
for ratification and of course virginia
last year became the 38th state to
ratify but last year the
justice department issued a um a memo
saying that you can't do that that if
you the only way to add this
era to the constitution is to start the
ratification process over
my question is whether the
administration is going to rescind that
memo as some democrats have asked him to
do
that's an excellent question i will have
to talk to our team about that and get
an update on it which we'll venture to
do for you after the briefing go ahead
thanks jen
uh there's a couple questions on behalf
of the print pool for reporters who
couldn't be here and then
one of my own jessie hellman with modern
healthcare
wanted to know uh in when president
biden's with the executives today
from johnson and johnson and mark does
he print does he plan to press
them on the increasing costs of
prescription drugs and does he plan to
bring up his own
agenda to lower drug prices the the
primary focus of this meeting is on
working together the the two companies
who have long been competitors
working together uh to ensure the
efficient and effective manufacturing of
vaccines okay
tommy christopher from media had a
question on the filibuster
uh said that uh president biden
expressed some openness
to filibuster referring to the camp i
know you've said more recently that it's
not his preference to change the rules
but he wants to know if
uh the john lewis voting rights act uh
represents a red line if republicans
do not support that if that does not
move forward in the senate is that
a red line that would prompt him to
consider filibuster reform or anything
well the president's preference is not
to
make changes to the filibuster rules he
believes that
voting rights and access to voting
ensuring it's easier for the american
people is
enough of a huge priority and should be
for everyone that's why he signed some
executive orders
used the power of the presidency to do
that this weekend and he is
hopeful that democrats and republicans
can work together to get that done
and then one last question the overall
agenda you were saying earlier you know
when you look at buildback better
you're sort of thinking through kind of
what's next but broadly speaking is
infrastructure the next
big legislative priority on capitol hill
for this administration
there's also pressure for an immigration
bill to go through
what's next for you guys what is the
next big priority after
uh the bill that you're hoping to sign
the president's hoping to sign on friday
it's a very popular question
understandably but our focus is on
getting the american rescue plan
implemented we will have more to say the
president will have more to say on his
buildback better agenda and what uh the
components of that look like
what size the proposals the
order of events will be uh but i don't
have anything to preview you
immigration bill on capitol hill well i
don't have a legislative order to
preview for you either i will say
given all the conversations we're having
understandably about
uh the border and uh questions about the
border
in the president's proposed immigration
package he has a
funding for to address the root causes
in the region as we talked about a
little bit earlier
he has a pathway to citizenship he
proposes a pathway to
citizenship for undocumented immigrants
and he also
proposes an investment in smart security
so
given all of the concern uh by many
uh in congress about uh immigration and
what's happening
at the border that sure seems like a
good time to to move that
initiative forward um go ahead in the
back thank you jen i
understand you don't want to call it
crisis from the podium but why do you
say the
patrol agents at the border especially
those within the union
who are calling it a crisis and who are
saying that they're overworked and
there's just
too many uh encounters day in and day
out
we are saying that we recognize uh that
uh on
incumbent upon us this administration is
contin to continue to work day and night
to expedite the process of uh of
ensuring there are the resources and
processes in place to
move children from the border patrol
facilities to the shelters
we are saying that it is incumbent upon
our administration to
uh look for additional facilities that
can safely house children
uh and incumbent upon us to ensure that
uh we are communicating
effectively and efficiently to the
region as ambassador jacobson
uh talked about at the top of this
briefing and those are all focuses
of the president on down uh you know
every single day
the mexican government today reports
that over 4 000
unaccompanied minors were actually
deported back to mexico between january
and march can you confirm that those
were done under the previous
administration were any of those
unaccompanied minors
deported under the dividend
administration i knew that cbp
provides numbers and date on a regular
basis and i think there's more data
coming
soon from there so i would certainly
send you to them for any statistics and
data our policy is that
we don't turn children under 18 away
at the border and of course as you know
though even if when they are in homes of
family members or uh in sponsored homes
that
they still can go through processing and
may need to return home
the stimulus package if i may one last
question i know i think this came up
yesterday but i wanted to re-ask the
question now that the stimulus package
is passed and many undocumented
immigrants are not benefited in any way
by uh the money that's going out does
the president plan any executive action
or anything else to do
to help the population sorry i missed
part of the last sentence
sure now that the stimulus package has
and the undocumented population many of
the millions are not benefited in any
way
does the president plan any executive
actions or anything else to help that
population
well certainly i think the president's
uh priority given he proposed an
immigration bill on the first day
is to create a pathway to citizenship
for 11 million undocumented immigrants
of course in this country he's also
clear that
ensuring that uh everybody in the
evening in this country is vaccinated uh
and receives access to
that uh covet 19 vaccine is a key
priority uh
and of course this is just the beginning
of his agenda but i don't have anything
more to preview for you
go ahead thank you given the current
progress on vaccination around the world
would the president consider organizing
his climate submit in person in dc
here for it to have more impact
i i don't think we have any i i think at
this point the intention is to do it
remotely i believe and i i don't think
there's an intention to change that but
i'm happy to check on that for you
and you know roughly how many heads of
state are expected to participate and if
the chinese
president would be one of them i don't
have any more details on the summit i
know it's coming up in about
six weeks five weeks uh and i expect as
we get closer we'll have more to preview
good go on the map oh yeah just a
follow-up on the filibuster so you've
said many times that
uh president biden's preference is not
to change the rules around filibuster
but if the next big pieces of his agenda
are stymied in the senate are there
changes to the filibuster that he can
live with
such as talking filibuster well the
president believes that there are a
range of issues where there's historic
um they're a historic precedent of
democrat republicans working together
whether it's infrastructure as we've
been talking about
or modernizing the immigration system
he's obviously had a number of
bipartisan meetings in the oval office
so
that's where his entered focus will be
moving forward
go in the back yeah um thank you a saudi
code
just held a troubled concerning a
dissident
a woman released from prison weeks ago
is it a sign that the
white house message uh regarding the
human rights abuse in the kingdom
is not strong enough you were referring
to a human rights uh somebody
a human rights activist who was released
from prisons but who
was not able to travel outside the
kingdom
i i would have to look into more
specific details of that i know we were
pleased with the release
but i'd have to look into more specific
details of the travel restrictions
what do you have any uh sort of epa for
when the next cabinet secretaries will
be approved
and when are you gonna start nominating
ambassadors go ask our friends in the
senate uh
we expect uh that some will move forward
with and and we are hopeful i should say
that we will get a couple of additional
cabinet members uh confirmed in the
coming days or over the course of the
next week the president's looking
forward to that
we're certainly looking forward to at
some point having a full cabinet meeting
uh the president hasn't made any
decisions about ambassadoral nominees so
uh i don't expect them to be confirmed
anytime soon given we have to nominate
them first
are you talking about sarah and
catherine kai uh well again it's really
up to the senate on the timeline for
that but we are hopeful that uh they
move forward
uh with the remaining members of the
cabinet uh given we are
uh almost two months into an
administration thank you jack um
just to follow up on something that
ambassador jacobson said
um i mean you may have gotten a note
about this
that she first time she said
um that the that the um
border is not closed and she then is
when she was speaking in spanish and
then
you know later on spoken spanish again
said the border is closed
i mean it seems like she i guess
misspoke the first time considering your
overall message but are you concerned
that now that she is misspoken that that
is going to be
you know picked up and and disseminated
across the spanish-speaking world as the
message from the administration
well given she also said that the border
is closed we're hopeful that
that is what will be picked up and uh
that has clearly and consistently been
our message uh so uh that is certainly
our hope
still at the same time you're having a
messaging difficulty around this issue
that just make it a little bit harder we
certainly hope not
we have the power of the media here to
make sure you're communicating
effectively with the messages and
as we know we all have moments where we
where we say something slightly
differently than we would like to and
we quickly try to correct it to make it
uh easier and effective for all of you
who are just trying to
communicate with the administration's uh
you know goals and policies are
thanks everyone
you